une semaine que ces cuisiniers n'arrête
pas après le click and collect et les
livraisons traditionnels ce restaurant
s'est mis à la vente dans une grande
surface
la faille a ramené 10 le soir même et
puis mercredi un ami donc non ça part
très vite les gens sont satisfaits
pour cette nouvelle clientèle il a fallu
s'adapter
combien de grammes les enfants à prendre
par exemple à remplir les étiquettes de
supermarché c'est pour rendre au
supermarché
direction la grande surface à deux
kilomètres du restaurant
pour maryline chatelier c'est un motif
d'espoir dans un contexte morose pour
les restaurateurs
c'est une opération à mon avis qui va ça
rêve va s'avérer fructueuse et qui va
nous permettre peut-être de résister
encore plus jusqu'à 30 notre ouverture à
peine arrivé et les clients se jette sur
ses plats du jour pour mac et étiquettes
et si vous voulez je vous donne une
petite barquette juste après je
m'attende qu'ils me donnent les
étiquettes pour le code barres du
bistrot on connaît on sait que c'est des
bons produits en ans trouvant là bas on
prend emporté c'est une super idée une
façon ils ont pas le choix il faut bien
qu'ils arrivent à vivre donc voilà
s'associe avec avec une grande surface
pour proposer ces produits là c'est
cette offre en contrepartie le
supermarché pour une commission 20% sur
le prix de vente
c'est un partenariat gagnant gagnant
c'est
voilà ça leur donne un petit coup pouce
nier puis va nous ça nous permet de
travailler encore du local dans le
magasin du côté de marilyn chasse
teulier comme de la grande surface
on souhaite poursuivre ce partenariat
même après la réouverture des
restaurants